alright ladies pick up your tests we're
going out what do you mean going out
what do you mean what do I mean we just
sucked balls in front of DJ Khaled hmm
listening he's staying at that fancy
casino hotel across the street okay I
say we all get up we get dressed we go
over there and we show him that we are
not a joke Emily I can't believe that a
half-decent ID came out of your dumb
mouth thank you okay so let's get tot it
up it's had it and toss it shells like
that
Tasha job she means to she's a caramel
tart she's a chocolate tot you're the
vanilla Todd thanks babe mmm Oh tarted
targets easy I will just say [ __ ]
what about artists you didn't know were
Jewish
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a ladder that will take you up to
the main deck where the Bellas are do
not live Turkish he what I'm doing below
okay
giant distraction coming up you sure
about this I ever let you down dozens of
examples spring to mind if I'm honest
yeah you're very unreliable it's like
one of the hallmarks of your personality
I don't think we have time to unpack
that right now Shh
I'll just say up top nobody's gonna die
tonight right Yeah right
yeah well that doesn't help okay
okay ready I've got my serious face on
now okay it's time let's do it
and we were always gonna be there for
each other it's we're family
Becca don't I swear to God don't make
that face
if you cry I'm gonna cry I'm not gonna
do this with you today so good I hate
that face no no it's not regular face
you know how much I love you you just
get out there and you crush it okay you
crush it so hard that your nips tingle a
bit she loves her don't
[Applause]
and as predicted Gail the Bellas are in
over their heads lost in a sea of semen
[Music]
[Music]
so what do you miss thing tonight a
little who run the world some
bulletproof you didn't tell us what the
crowd was but sheet I um I brought this
just make oh God
our voices are warm we didn't invite you
guys to sing we invited you to watch us
sing excuse me I just thought you guys
were so busy with your your awesome jobs
and amazing lives I have one of those
yeah
and as predicted Gail the Bellas are in
over their heads lost in a sea of semen
[Music]
baby I
[Music]
you guys are seeing other people's songs
right oh my god okay stop they just
don't like sharing the spotlight so
they're trying to intimidate us let's
just take the high road and do what we
do
I think what I'm thinkin money's a
riff-off
[Music]
coming up so you go
[Music]
rolling in my six ball with my Bella
[Music]
you'd be most amazing group of women I
have ever known
I would do anything to sing with you
guys again
wait wait wait wait wait I'm having a
crazy idea
okay I've mentioned that my dad is in
the army and like basically killed Osama
bin Laden right some no information in
that sentence but okay well what I mean
is he's kind of a big deal in the Army
and every year the USO puts on this
performance to entertain and support the
troops and this year dj khaled is
hosting he's got like that gazillion hit
songs and you super famous I saw him on
a tax commercial what if I could get us
an invite just say no to run military
dark ops yes of course to say
you
you
singing when it doesn't even be singing
while it's coming in a little bit gonna
burst
so I'm gonna leave
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you stop it you just know let's go to
the mansion or the condo let's go
Birkett I've got a let it flow you know
I'm watching
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
and marks on B
don't they all
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey Mark
you